[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce parfum spécial
consacré au problème du séparatisme de
la radicalisation islamique avec pour en
parler magali lac rose bonjour vous êtes
le journaliste notamment c dans l'air et
vous êtes l'auteur avec patrick karam
qui vice président du conseil régional
d'île de france qui devait être avec
nous et qui vient un problème personnel
vous êtes l'auteur du livre noir du
sport alors on va en parler
dans cette émission évidemment c'est pas
un livre contre le sport vous
reconnaissez toutes les valeurs du sport
mais vous parlez de certaines dérives
les violences sexuelles le l'homophobie
le racisme est aussi le séparatisme qui
est qui rentre dans un certain nombre de
clubs de sport avec 12,6 vous staff à la
ba oui bonjour dont jean patrice vous
êtes vous avez été longtemps le
président du football club de trappes
vous êtes le 14 à 14 ans vous êtes le
président fahva citoyens vous êtes aussi
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
trappes et donc vous avez un regard
évidemment et sur le terrain et sur ce
que vous avez fait qu'ils étaient très
importants au football club de trappes
peut-être pour faciliter la citoyenneté
un accès à la citoyenneté d'un certain
nombre de deux jeunes avec nous aussi
jacqueline eustache brinio bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice du val
d'oise et vous êtes la coauteure si je
peux dire d'un rapport très très
édifiant est très passionnant sur la
radicalisation islamiste et les moyens
de la combattre
tout à fait il ya aussi avec nous rémy
en grand bonjour vous êtes directeur de
la communication de souffle ou des
vignes sont plus des vignerons c'est bon
il ya vous êtes aussi un spécialiste
d'un certain nombre de quartiers dont on
dit qu'ils sont défavorisés on en
parlerait vous faites une action
formidable justement en faveur de ces
quartiers et puis avec nous et dans
l'anonymat
la crise bonjour genre alors je dis tout
de suite c'est pas votre nom vous êtes
là anonyme pourquoi parce que vous êtes
un acteur de terrain dans l'est dans les
quartiers dits prioritaires et pour des
raisons évidentes parce que vous êtes
confrontés justement chaque jour à la
réalité de ces quartiers
vous allez témoigner de manière anonyme
mais ce que vous allez nous dire est
assez édifiant et est très fort alors on
va peut-être commencer par l'actualité
l'actualité c'était le discours aux
mureaux d'emmanuel macro c'est le thème
du séparatisme
[Musique]
je vais peut-être commencer par vous
madame la sénatrice jacqueline eustache
brinio vous êtes donc je disais l'auteur
de ce rapport sur le sur la
radicalisation islamiste
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé justement
de ce discours c'est c'était c'était un
rapport qui appelait un peu ce discours
du président de la république
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez qu'elle
quelle est votre analyse de ce discours
des des mesures qui sont proposés à
d'abord merci de donner la parole
oui c max ce rapport appelait une
réaction politique parce que on peut
parler ce sujet à tous les niveaux s'il
n'y a pas une réaction politique ait une
ligne ça qu'on va faire revanche sur le
discours il a eu le mérite de poser les
choses on avait lu des articles avec le
séparatisme d'un canesse on parle
clairement du séparatistes islamistes
ça c'était extrêmement important
d'entendre ça après avec les moyens de
deux peut-être lutter contre
effectivement ce que des quartiers sous
vis ce qu'une partie de la population
subit ce que notre pays la france subit
par cet entrisme de l'islamisme que je
ne qualifie pas de radical parce que
pour moi l'islamisme c'est un projet
politique il ya l'islam et à la religion
musulmane que vos l'acquisition par un
syndrome de nos concitoyens qui pose pas
pour elle et l islamisme et islam is
c'est un combat politique c'est une
ligne politique alors il a parlé de
nissan et ce radical moi je ne donne pas
d'objectif en islamistes islamique c'est
un projet politique larmes
on ya pas d islamisme modéré enfin ça
veut rien dire cela après moi je donc
voilà il a donné un certain nombre de
règles de cases sur les piscines sur les
pouvoirs de nouveau préfet sur le fait
de préserver l'école sur tellement tout
ça c'est extrêmement important
après je m'interroge parce que président
il a toujours c'est cette espèce de
positions permanente de dire et puis de
nuances et de l'autre côté il a parlé de
l'étude de la langue arabe
moi je ne vois pas ce que ça vient faire
là dedans j'en reparlerai si vous donnez
la parole tout à l'heure il met 10
millions à la fondation volet sam de
france pour quoi faire
pour quoi faire je m'interroge voilà
vraiment ça je m'interroge et donner les
clés incertain de nos personnes sans
avoir clarifié la facette et six lames
politique ça ça me paraît important donc
c'est vrai que ce texte de loi est
nécessaire ou pas je ne sais pas ce
qu'il y aura dans le texte de loi et au
sénat on y sera très très attentif mais
je pense que nous avons une chose à
préserver de manière très claire c'est
la france avec ce qu'elle offre à tout
tout à chacun à tout le monde
en dehors des sphères religieuses et moi
si vous voulez ce double discours
m'interroge c'est à dire que on frappe
d'un côté mais on dit attention on n'est
pas méchants mais on n'est pas méchants
on est méchant avec personne les
musulmans ne pose pas problème dont pays
nous avons des milliers des millions de
musulmans qui assurent qu'ils suivent
leur flotte sans poser problème dans la
sphère privée comme beaucoup de croyants
mais nous avons une partie de musulmans
qui ont un vrai projet politique qui ont
infiltré ce pays parce que ce pays a des
forces né à des faiblesses ont abusé de
la faiblesse de démocratie c'est clair
de la faiblesse de nos lois on alors là
et qui se sont infiltrés dans certains
quartiers dans des pans entiers de la
république et c'est ce qui nous pose
problème
donc oui et la dig il a posé tu mets de
côté
il n'a pas voulu heurter et je pense que
là il à moi ce volet-là m'inquiète
clairement aujourd'hui moi ce qui
m'inquiète c'est que en ouvrant ce côté
voilà on va donner des moyens
à la fondation l'islam pour la france
qui serra on est en train quelque part
de nous emmener
c'est ça qui m'inquiète même société
multiculturelle la france n'est pas
multi culturelle elle a une sainte
culture dans lequel nous devons tous de
reconnaître
voilà tous elle est multiconfessionnelle
ça ça pose aucun problème
on a tous des régions différents ou pas
parce que calme la plupart des gens qui
vise à ce prix sont hâtés info juste le
rappeler voilà c'est un fait mais c'est
pas et nous emmener dans le
multiculturalisme mais qui est un peu sa
servante craignais pardon c'était je
pense que ce que ce que vous disiez dans
le rapport c'est que c'est que ils vous
disent il faut agir vite parce que des
pans entiers du territoire risquent de
sortir de la république c'est ça votre
crainte bien sûr et je pense qu'elle est
personnes qui sont autour de vous pour
on vous le dira
7 cette commission dans clac elle le
pose clairement il y a des écosystèmes
dans certains quartiers où on sent les
enfants de l'école où on ne va pas au
sport parce que le sport vous apposez
rennes qu'on ne veut pas respectés ou
les boutiques sont rachetés par une
communauté et donc on a des enfants des
quartiers qui finalement deux vivent
repliés sur eux mêmes dans un écosystème
où la loi de la république ne passe plus
où ce sont les règles religieuses qui
s'imposent et nous n'avons pas construit
notre société pour ça notre france notre
pays on vit pas les uns à côté des
autres mais les uns avec les autres
laissé pour probablement pour les
enfants et pour ses quartiers voilà les
plus en difficulté que nous devons nous
battre pour pas qu'ils en sortent parce
que vous avez des influences forte dans
ces quartiers là moi là je donc je les
connais ses quartiers dans la vie moi
j'ai été maire 18 ans un quartier petit
un quartier de l'abbaye
il ya des femmes qui subissent des
pressions terribles qui n'ont pas les
moyens de résister et ces pressions là
effectivement il ya des femmes des
jeunes des moins jeunes et qui subissent
ces pressions religieuses dans un
objectif c'est de les gérer et de les
faire obéir à des lois religieuses
c'est une réalité
on ne peut pas le nier avant de demander
à l'érection de vagues à vis de mustapha
de rebih peut-être crise puisque vous
vivez dans ces quartiers quel et vous
votre votre réaction est votre analyse
et enfin racontez-nous profond comment
vous vivez ce que vous vivez non
j'entends ce que la sénatrice dit
qu'elle ne comprend pas qu'elle était de
comprendre le discours de monsieur macro
alors je pense que là au tournoi de
votre table vous avez des gens
intelligents et je pense qu'ils savent
tout ce que tu avais de force que je
vais dire mais je pense que vous avez
perdu le combat ils sont déjà implantés
ils sont déjà
est ce déjà très avancé on a fait plus
de 10 15 ans mais les envoie il reste
pas beaucoup de temps voilà c'est tout
ce que je peux vous dire pour l'instant
sur le trio madame moustache et qu'en
fait en effet de dépiauter de bricoler
de mettre de la rustine alors fait déjà
partie c'est pour moi c'est trop tard
vous avez perdu la france c'est aussi
parce que on entend ce que vient de dire
ce jeune homme que nous étions peu
nombreux
jusqu'à présent le dénoncer un parce que
est vraiment ce que vous avez dit
monsieur je l'entends moi je suis une
combattante de la ligue
j'ai eu des procès sur le dos contre ces
gens là pendant dix ans donc je les
connais parfaitement
il a raison de dire que c'est un peu
tard après moi je suis une espèce de
résidents de résistance on peut pas dire
c'est trop tard nous amène il a raison
il a raison mais il ya deux explications
à ça c'est qu'il ya eu dit
alors là je le dis clairement du
clientélisme politique qui a fait qu'on
les a laissés s'installer à droite comme
à gauche moi je suis les lieux de droite
il y en a de tous les côtés et y en a
encore qui sont dans l'oubli aujourd'hui
après le rapport du sénat après le livre
de patrick karam et la journaliste qui
est à vos côtés
après le rapport du député diard ump cdu
qui sont dans le déni c'est
insupportable il a raison de dire c'est
aussi une responsabilité collective
c'est aussi une responsabilité saisine
les élus ne peuvent pas donner faire
répondre s'ils voulaient le problème
c'est que vous avez une par exemple dans
les listes municipales des élus qui ne
viennent pas pour parler d'un projet
politique pour la ville mais qui
viennent en disant je t'apporte et bois
des mosquées si tu me prends et tu seras
lui ça c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable quand on vient dans une
liste municipale
on vient parce qu'on a une ambition
collective quelle que soit sa couleur de
peau quelles que soient ses origines
quelle que soit sa religion
on a un projet en commun on ne vient pas
là au nom d'une communauté et ce mot
communauté d'ailleurs pour l'emploi
tellement dans ce pays qu'on va finir
par le parcours qui a vu des communautés
qui vivent les hinako d'élise
non il ya une nation il ya un pays et on
doit se retrouver dans cette nation dans
ce pays
alors nous sommes à la bouille d'andrew
jeudi à ce jeune homme que c'est
courageux ce qu'il a dit ce serait à ce
qu'on entend ça nous les élus république
a résisté ne pas baisser les bras
vrai c'est d'autant plus courageux crise
bardon mais que dans les quartiers où
vous êtes vous n'avez jamais vu aucun
responsable de la politique de la ville
de venir avec vous wayne on me fait du
business tout ça c'est dit business
chacun garde son poste
chacun garde sous son petit emploi c'est
ça part de là haut jusqu'en bas
et après nous on y fait de bric en était
de s'en sortir que mon plan bas sauf
qu'on et voilà il ya la délinquance
aussi savent ce que cela par delà les
jeunes ils ont plus aucun repère donc
forcément y croit plus en personne et il
ya des défilés qui sont là pour les
attraper et leur expliquer comment il a
dit plus les financements obscures donc
c'est parfait je vous dis que c'est
perdu
c'est interdit une fresque part nommé
juge qu'il ya personne qui le dit mais
je pense que ce ne serait ce que dans
par là les élections vous le voyez un
électorat qui fait qui sait lire par
rapport à ce tous et tous ces problèmes
donc on est moche je vous vois pas
comment la france peut s'en sortir ou si
la france elle s'en sort allait il va
falloir mettre le paquet maintenant
pendant 20 ans jamais les discours qu'y
qu'ils sortent du président ou de
l'ancien président je suis pas pro
macron de tout le monde
c'est un problème collectif où tout le
monde est fait de se faire élire sur ces
problèmes là voilà ce que je vois et
puissent d'appareils le staff à la bri
vous êtes de fra vous avez de football
club de trappes donc vous connaissez
vous vivez ces questions là alors tout
d'abord dire que c'est trop tard
ça voudra dire que l'action politique
n'a pas de sens par définition il n'y a
plus rien à faire
donc même cette émission finalement ça
serait l'émission de trop tôt trop
puisque il n'y a plus rien à faire donc
chers amis c'est brice je crois qui
crissent on dénonce est en réalité moi
je le dis sur ce plateau et de façon
totalement transparente et je viens sur
votre plateau pour le dire on le dénonce
depuis des années quand j'entends
finalement madame la sénatrice dire
c'est important de le dénoncer mais mais
c'est bien que les politiques viennent
de dénoncer maintenant mais moi qui suis
sur le terrain qu'il parte politique de
lui depuis maintenant aller une bonne
trentaine d'années mais qui sur le
terrain associatif on le dénonce déjà
mais sur le terrain on fait que ça on
dénonce effectivement que de plus en
plus la loi de 1905 est d'avouer que le
mode associatif dans son expression
on ya beaucoup de gens qui sortent de
l'objet de l'associatif et qui utilise
les clubs sportifs qui est clé qui
existe qui utilisent les clubs
associatifs pour effectivement faire de
l'entrisme mais ça madame la sénatrice
on le dénonce depuis des années et c'est
bien que les politiques se soit en
parler de ce débat que les journalistes
se soit emparé du sujet je vais même
plus loin ont dénoncé des choses sans
véritablement les connaître parce qu'on
a l'impression que quand on vit sur le
terrain et quand on est dans ces
quartiers
quand on est à proximité de la
population et des quartiers en
particulier au passage on ne parle que
des quartiers depuis tout à l'heure mais
en réalité c'est répondu au delà des
frontières françaises c'est à
l'international que pourrait porter le
sujet
en france et au delà des quartiers mais
si on veut rester sur les quartiers je
veux bien en parler aussi
mais on voit les choses émerger on voit
les choses à paraître et quand les
politiques s'en empare ou quand les
journalistes s'en empare on révèle des
choses il ya des enquêtes qui sont
faites nous les hommes de terrain on
dénonce certaines pratiques on dénonce
certaines choses mais à qui on les
dénoncer à l'époque à nos politiques
mais par définition nos politiques
il y avait effectivement cette notion de
clientélisme qui bloquait to address is
est quand même à droite comme à gauche
la sénatrice comme si madame la
sénatrice les élus pensaient sincèrement
que il existait une masse informe et que
ce serait aux meilleurs d'entre nous de
réussir à prendre cette masse totale des
musulmans pour les faire voter d'un côté
comme de l'autre
certains ont pensé que c'était même des
islamo gauchiste s'était dit rien on
mélange et le monde musulman avec le
monde ou socialisme avec des difficultés
sociales donc c'est le prolétariat de
l'époque donc l'islamo gauchisme c'est
de dire cette masse de musulmans qui ne
réfléchissent pas qu'ils savent pas ce
qu'ils veulent par définition c'est la
gauche qui va sûrement paraît l'islamo
gauchisme à droite
ne tombez pas dans le piège de cette
masse venez nous rejoindre alors qu'en
réalité il ya autant de vision de la
religion musulmane kia de musulmans 99
99 % des musulmans que je connais que je
côtoie vivent leurs pratiques et leur
religion de façon apaisée
on est face à un problème effectivement
d'une minorité extrêmement extrêmement
légère qui fait beaucoup de bruit qui
fait beaucoup de mal et à un moment
donné il faut qu'on se mette autour de
la table
donc moi si je peux revenir sur ce que
vous aviez posé comme question au tout
début
c'est à dire rapidement le séparatisme
me prononcer par emmanuel macron moi ce
qui me fait plaisir c'est que quelque
part on a mis on a dit il faut passer à
l'action
moi je vous le dis franchement j'ai un
avis totalement différent et je crois
que je n'ai pas entendu son rauque un
plateau de télé mais je trouve qu'on
veut trop nommer les choses on veut trop
donner des définitions et comme le
curseur on sait pas où le mettre
entre musulmans islam entre islamistes
islamiste radical islamiste modéré
musulmans modérés et puis d'un seul coup
on sait plus où on met des définitions
des contres définition tout le monde s
approprier des mots non arrêtez moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on dise
élections c'est qu'on dise dans ce pays
a des lois la loi 1901 et on va pas
toucher à l'objet 05 plutôt des loi 1901
et on veut pas toucher aux projets d d
objets d loi 1901 des associations il ya
la loi de 1905 à l'éclair et il faut
revenir dessus et ne pas en sortir
ensuite il existe même la justice s'il
ya des délits je parlerai de délits on a
des moyens on a des juges on a des
renseignements généraux
bref on a tout un arsenal qui fait que
sur cette minorité on peut y travailler
à une condition c'est qu'on souhaite
tous d'accord que les musulmans comme
toutes les religions sont apaisées en
réalité que la dignité des uns et des
autres est-ce qu'il ya plus important
les gens ont droit de croire et ce qui
protège par définition cette communauté
comme les autres c'est la loi de 1905
c'est les notions de citoyenneté
donc à un moment donné tous ces débats
moi je veut bien les entendre mais à
vouloir nommer nommé faire des
pléonasmes de moi je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut arrêter et passer à
l'action
c'est intéressant pour s'arrête urbain
finit là dessus de patrice il est
intéressant que le président donne des
pistes menant des actions que le livre
de madame effectivement puisse donner
des pistes
patrick karam qui n'est pas là
aujourd'hui a lancé cette notion de
charte pour les associations
voilà il ya plein d'outils ce qu'on doit
s'emparer d'autre qu'un doit travailler
mais nous je le dis ici on le dénonce
depuis longtemps
merci aux politiques de nous rejoindre
de nous entendre et passer à l'action
mais pas simplement sur le fait
religieux
on parle aussi de la ghettoïsation
depuis les années démarche de moyens
depuis des années de l'éducatif depuis
des années et puis de la répression
depuis des années que justement avant de
passer la parole à magali rémy en grand
justement est ce que c'est vous qui
connaissait aussi des quartiers
difficiles est-ce que c'est trop tard
comme le dit crise ou est ce qui encore
un peu d'espoir à écouter dans
l'affirmation de notre témoin crise
j'entends beaucoup de désespoir
république la république plutôt une
promesse d'espoir là on parle de
séparatisme on parle de phénomène de
désagrégation sociale
moi je m'interroge sur la capacité du
désespoir à créer du lien entre les gens
donc à mon sens il faut plutôt
effectivement il a je donne je ne
tournera pas vers le ciel harbaoui dont
j'entends le discours du pont est
effectivement offert il faut il faut il
faut y croire il faut avancer si
positivement et savard créer de l'espoir
recréer du lien social là où en
l'occurrence jédir et le remplit la
défiance la rupture a tendance à prendre
à prendre de plus en plus de terrain et
pour cela évidemment l'action politique
l'innovation politique fera la
différence alors c'est bien on a un
président aujourd'hui qui veut qu'un
république qui veut qui veut ramener la
république au bas des tours comme il l'a
dit un mois je parle de ce que je
connais les quartiers le week-end je
suis pas je suis pas du tout un
spécialiste de l'islam politique ou du
radicalisme du radicalisme maintenant
pour ramener la république aurait dit
aux gars évidemment la contrainte mais
ça ne suffit pas la république sait on
l'a dit une promesse d'espoir maintenant
la république ne peut pas fonctionner
uniquement par un jour il va falloir
aussi redonné envie de république ça ça
passe par des politiques de fond qui
vont s'attaquer à des problématiques
d'éducation de culture de citoyenneté et
par un plan gérer un peu ambitieux sur
le long terme qui permettra un moment de
refaire gros et de refaire nation pour
reprendre votre nom latin de la
sénatrice puisque l'idée de nation et de
cohésion nationale est extrêmement
important alors un mot de madame la
sénatrice jacqueline eustache brinio
parce que je vais devoir vous libérer
dans quelques instants
j'ai relevé des réactions au discours de
mac rentrait imposé par exemple il ya
celle de manon aubry veut savait qui
était la tête de liste des
des insoumis oui aux européennes elle
dit steam stigmatiser les musulmans
c'est son unique solution
et puis une réaction une réaction alors
absolument opposé de quelqu'un qui parle
politique mais qui parle de votre
politique et michel onfray qui dit
j'imagine le grand rire
le grand rire des salafistes et des
terroristes en devenir si l'on écouté ce
long pensum inutile week les réactions
sont totalement des métral boffod posés
çà devrait dire justement ce que disait
mustapha larfaoui c'est à dire qu on a
déjà les les éléments qu'il faut agir
sur le terrain plutôt que de parler
qu'est-ce que quelle est votre réaction
par rapport à ça moi je voudrais dire
des politiques qui dénoncent
il y en a eu nous n'étions pas beaucoup
moi je dénonce depuis longtemps ce
phénomène j'ai été extrêmement menacée
moi je peux me dire ce que vous dépensez
que vous mettez clairement michibata je
peux vous assurer que c'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille et que vous êtes
extrêmement menacée sauf que faut
toujours être plus forts que ceux qui
vous menace mais il faut que la peur
change de camp et moi je n'ai jamais eu
peur donc effectivement nous n'étions
pas beaucoup à le dénoncer les
journalistes non plus n'était pas
beaucoup à le dénoncer
parce qu'en fait on s'aperçoit même on
s'aperçoit en s'apercevant de six ont
dénoncé ce problème on était souvent
associé à l'extrême droite extrême
moi j'ai aucun état d'âme là dessus je
sais où je suis je sais voilà non mais
c'était ça le truc fascine c'est vous
êtes des fachos ce manque aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'on dit une fasciste et de
raciste voilà bon car il faut dépasser
ces boues qui ne veulent rien dire les
journalistes les journalistes avaient
peur aussi de dénoncer ça parce que et
là effectivement il si on dénonce trop
fait le lit du front national
mais celle inverse qui s'est passé
exactement inverse s'est passé c'est en
ne dénonçant pas qu'ils ont pris des
places c'est en ne dénonçant pas qu'ils
ont pris des places et c'est ça la
limite d'aujourd'hui circle
nous devons effectivement collectivement
battre contre ce phénomène parce que
effectivement mon la france est aussi
une la mort alors je vais pas faire un
grand disque aulas plus parce que c est
long mais la france elle est la cible et
la signe parce que c'est le pays de la
laïcité la laïcité labat bête noire des
salafis ça c'est clair et que la console
est regardé par d'autres pays oui un
projet politique derrière tout ça à nous
de le déconseiller à nous le dire quand
vous avez des l'élue d'extrême gauche ou
de force a soumis ce qu'ils ont des
propos comme ça évidemment eux ils en
font leur soupe électorale donc c'est
clair
sauf que au lieu d'aider leur électorat
à s'intégrer dans la république a essayé
de leur donner de dire on va vous donner
les mêmes chances niveau les laisser là
où ils sont parce qu'ils auraient un
intérêt politique
ça c'est juste scandaleux voilà nous
n'avons ensemble ensemble a écrit
recettes phares mais telle page
elle ne peut pas s'écrire et je rejoins
et de ceux qui se battent ce plateau
s'il n'y a pas un discours clair s'il
n'y a pas une claire et s'il n'y a pas
une trajectoire politique clair on ne
peut rien faire sans ça vraiment ça j'en
suis au stade où je vous libère je
souscris totalement à ce que vous venez
de dire madame la sénatrice
effectivement c'était important de le
dire les choses et penser que ne rien
dire c'était justement ne pas alimenter
le front national c'est effectivement
linverse vous avez totalement raison
en revanche madame la sénatrice je
trouve qu'on ne donne pas suffisamment
la parole en tous les cas c'est ce que
moi je compte bien faire aux 99 % des
musulmans qui quittent entre guillemets
peuvent vivre ce que vit ce monsieur
dans l'anonymat c'est à dire je peux pas
le dire parce que j'ai peur de le dire
parce qu'il est j'ai franchement on
l'entend mais ça veut bien dire qu'ils
sont tous dans le même camp ils sont
donc comme la république son camp la
laïcité dans le temps la citoyenneté
par contre par contre qu'ils conviennent
pas les heurter dans leur dignité de
croyants dans leur dignité à prier dans
leur dignité à exercer leur culte mais
la très grande majorité est donc
stratégiquement on ferait une erreur a
continué les polémiques dans les
polémiques pour finalement arriver à
nous dit
viser à nous séparer le séparatisme il
est bon pour ceux qui le souhaitent
c'est à dire ceux qui sont très peu
nombreux le séparatisme nous permettrait
d'augmenter leurs troupes
pat séparatisme soyons convaincus de la
loi 1901 danoise 1905 et de tout
l'arsenal qu'on peut obtenir
mais gardons l'idée en tête de la
dignité des uns et des autres la loi de
1905 permet à tout le monde de prier
d'exercer son culte c'est la liberté par
définition et je crois que sur le
terrain il faut continuer à l'expliquer
en tout cas nous ce qu'on fait dans un
club de foot on l'a fait dans beaucoup
d'endroits mais voilà je pense qu'il ya
un an j'ai envie de dire au boulot au
boulot ok si vous voulez dire un mot
avant de recruter de la main dans la
main stage brio après je crois que voilà
nous avons un objectif commun un
objectif commun c'est de travail c'est
de préserver l'unité de ce pays
voilà au nom de la république je pense
que c'est un objectif commun que nous
fera sans tabou sans dénis laissant
leurs devoirs je pense que c'est
l'essentiel
et nous y arrivons si on a ce courage là
voilà ce que j'ai pour donner un peu
d'espoir à crise parce que d'entendre
des propos de ça me heurter ça me fait
de la peine
donc voilà je réagis vie dans les
quartiers arrivé voilà ils racontent ce
qu'ils voient femmes et des filles donc
ma mère vit dans un quartier mais voilà
elle lui dira devant la chose devrait
lui laisser un message d'espoir vraiment
merci merci merci beaucoup madame la
sénatrice je renvoie à ce rapport qui
est public qui était publié en juillet
dernier au sénat sur le radicalisme des
moyens de lutte et de le combattre
merci à niveau et en parler parce
qu'elle a été très sage des femmes merci
jusqu'à présent avec magali lac rose on
va parler justement 10 sport alors il ya
beaucoup de jeux de choses que vous
évoquez dans le sport mais on va
commencer justement sur ce thème le
sport et la radicalisation
[Musique]
alors justement dans ce livre vous vous
tout un chapitre qui y est consacrée qui
s'appelle quand la religion gagne le
sport vous expliquer il ya des
témoignages de vous avez beaucoup de
témoignages qui sont tout à fait
passionnant de gens qui explique voilà
qu'on peut pas se mettre nue dans un
vestiaire que et la mixité pose des
problèmes enfin il ya une multiples
exemples dans les clubs de sport sur
cette radicalisation
oui mais sondés parfois souvent il
s'agit de témoignages qui on a été
anonyme comme les jeux de monsieur
pourquoi
et c'est ce que ce que vous expliquez
tout à l'heure c'est que on est dans une
omerta complète qui qui a besoin d'être
nommé notamment pas que mes par la
politique par des discours et par d
par des affirmations claire de ce que de
ce que sont les règles dans le sport
qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi dans
certains dans certains endroits dans
certains clubs
quelles que soient les disciplines ans
pourquoi certaines personnes peuvent
plus facilement exercer leur culte prier
dans un vestiaire où dans une salle qui
était qui étaient installés pour ne pas
avoir le droit de ne pas serrer la main
de femme ou de refuser d'avoir une
éducatrice sportive au féminin pourquoi
à partir d'un moment donné ça a été
rendue possible
c'est là c'est la question de les aider
alors est ce qui est ce que vous le
dater sa ce qui met un moment où c'est
entrer dans les clubs de sport ou est ce
que c'est un phénomène de plus en plus
présent le sport c'est pas le problème
le nom mais il sent exister en revanche
les services de renseignement français
eux le date et l'ont officialisé dans
des notes en termes qui par ailleurs on
était rendu public en 2015 ils ont
identifié le sport amateur comme comme
un espace comme un vecteur de
communautarisme et de radicalisation
donc c'est à voir qui leur vendent sans
l'esprit se feront dans steam aux
prévisions trop de personnes
radicalisées a qui sont dans les clubs
de sport enfin 2 c'est ça aussi encore
c'est ce qu'on se dit qu'il est le le
phénomène de vous en tant que
journaliste et vous avez enquêté vous
avez recueilli cd voyage qui vous a le
plus choqué ou plus inquiété dont les
comportements dans au chapitre allait
donc dans ces hôpitaux parlera de deux
restent tout à l'heure en fait le point
commun de tous ces témoignages haut de
l'arc de cette absence de liberté parole
c'est une
une souffrance une souffrance des uns et
des autres je me souviens d'une d'une
jeune fille qui qui pour le coup était
très bonne dans cette discipline et d'un
seul coup parce qu' un membre de sa
famille était adepte de théories radical
est par ailleurs ne savez pas lire
l'arabe littéraire et donc on lui avait
dit qu'il ne fallait pas faire de sport
pour les femmes
pour respecter la région elle a été
retirée de son club et elle est arrivée
en larmes en disant voilà je vais plus
pouvoir faire ma passion ça ce sont des
choses qui sont compliqués parce que on
est face à un moment donné à des esprits
qui ne sont pas ouverts qui ne veulent
pas écouter les lois de la république et
qui abîme d'autres d'autres personnes
dans la fête automnale crise justement
vous occupez de aussi de sport dans dans
les quartiers vrai que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes confrontés
justement à ces problèmes notamment sur
la mixité sur le fait qu' on vous dit ah
bah vaudrait mieux que les filles pas
avec les garçons et ses nouveaux amis
comme je vous ai dit pour nous c'est
normal pour nous c'est normal phenom je
me dis qu'il ya un fossé jeudi aux
parties se parlent et vous avez raison
tout petit j'ai l'impression j'entends
les émissions de télé tous les jours et
moi je vis de dons et bien choquant
quand vous parlez de radicalisation
venant nous fait comme ça en fait on vit
comme ça
les femmes avec les hommes l'arrêt de
des sports pendant l'heure de la prière
méga problème pour nous nous avait
habitués à vivre comme ça donc faux
cheveux alors donné ne peut pas mettre
la moitié d'un pied dans le quartier et
tout connaître
non pas possible moi je suis dedans j'ai
vu dedans je dis pas que toutes les
structures sont comme ça mais beaucoup
pour nous aussi
ouais c'est que tant qu ici parce que je
vous avais je travaille avec beaucoup de
villes c'est comme ça il n'y a pas de
problème entre nous y'a pas de problème
sa vie comme ça ça pose un problème
d'excès comme ancêtre voyons nous ça va
là vous avez des rappels a présidée
de trappes alors moi j'ai pas lu j'ai
pas lu votre sinon je n'ai pas je vais
pas envie de sortir vient de sortir d'où
le vrai et les passionnés
c'est sur la radicalisation mais c'est
également sur les violences noria
violences sexuelles aux phobies
j'imagine que tous les thèmes sont
abordés
mais concernant ce thème et pour revenir
sur les propos évoqués par crise moi je
mets pas en doute son témoignage
encore une fois je le dis ni témoigne
aujourd'hui à visage couvert moi j'en
connais plein de la même façon qu'ils
peuvent dire les choses de la même façon
ce qui prouve bien qu'on est nombreux à
les dénoncer et je les dénonce
et on est nombreux et j'ai envie de dire
c'est la grande majorité par contre qui
est des gens qui agissent pour aller
dans un autre sens c'est vrai et encore
une phase avait des années qu'on le dit
premièrement deuxièmement pour aller
dans quel sens va pour aller dans un
sens on va dire non pas de la religion
en tant que telle au passage moi je ne
commente pas les propos ni religieux ni
lait ni leader etc mais pour aller vers
un projet et éventuellement politiques
voire pour certains de bonne foi de dire
pour nous et canevas de bonne foi pour
un projet politique pour certains pour
des ambitions personnelles pour d'autres
et c'est tout on peut y trouver toutes
les toutes les tendances personnel mais
j'ai dirigé un club de foot moi
maintenant si vous me dites que il est
arrivé dans les quatorze ans de ma
présidence qu' il ya eu des joueurs qui
soyez dans un vestiaire pour faire une
prière crise me dira mais bien sûr que
ça existe on est même venu une fois à
trappes on l'a vu mais moi je vais pas
en douter une seconde
ça me met savez même arrivé de croiser
effectivement un groupe qui sortait d'un
vestiaire puisqu'ils sont collectivement
retrouver mais ce que je constate c'est
que quand le travail bien fait et encore
une fois je parle de d'un travail
concernant par exemple l'objet foot
l'objet sport il n'ya pas de place et
c'est extrêmement respectueux hommages à
12h tu arrêtes l'entraînement pour qu'on
aille prier
on ne m'a jamais dit tu arrêtes un match
de foot pour aller prier et 50 par
définition de la définition mon objet
c'était l'exercice de la pratique du
football
j'en étais extrêmement respectée pour ça
et les gens ils y allaient jouer au foot
et voulait des résultats et voulait la
pratique du foot j'y apporte et il se
trouve que moi j ai apporté il ya eu
beaucoup de témoignages elle est pas con
on n'écoutait pas beaucoup ce que je
disais moi je me souviens de radio de
télé de journalistes qui venaient me
voir qui me plaît avec lesquels je parlé
pendant deux heures pour dire ce qu'il
fallait faire et on voulait simplement
retenir qu'il ya un tel kiss et qui
s'est fait entre guillemets aller qui
s'est fait chambrer sur tel et tel
phénomène
et on l'a retenu on l'a mis dans un
livre on l'a retenu on l'a mis devant
une caméra
on l'a retenu on l'a mis devant donc la
politique d exemple la politique d des
phénomènes des phénomènes qui sont pour
le coup qui disent quelque chose je ne
lis pas je te vois partie des gens qui
nient au contraire j'arrête pas de dire
que je les constate et on l'a même
déploré on l'a dit souvent haut et fort
simplement aujourd'hui on veut des
témoignages mais qui sont les
témoignages extrêmement alors d'abord
soit ils sont anonymes
soit ce sont des témoignages personnels
et et on voit bien qu'on a envie d'en
faire quelque chose de entre guillemets
autour des exemples vivants mais le
phénomène mais le phénomène je répète le
phénomène existe sauf que nous on n'est
pas invité dans les réunions où ça se
pratique et où on a envie de nous
emmener sera prêt on n'est pas invité
dans ces réunions on n'est pas invités
de sur ce projet on donc non on voit ça
de l'extérieur
les exemples existent et il parle de
quelque chose il simplement il ya des
chila sûr il ya des exemples
il ya des chiffres mais encore une fois
est indemne mais quand je dis 99% de ce
crime qui précisément puisque 99 et
balayé par des exemples
le livre de magali scoop ce nouveau
score
phénomène est complètement taille si tu
n'aimes par ailleurs sur les véhicules
comme normal sur un mot par contre 14 en
pratique d'exercices du foot
j'ai également apporter cette idée de
citoyenneté et j'ai mis au décours
pharma citoyens qui est une autre
association que j'ai créé pharma
citoyens essaient de ses citoyens tous
mes mômes on allait régulièrement
allez pour vous dire en tous les cas
pour la classe que j'évoquais on a fait
le musée de la shoah tous les ans j'ai
créé une section féminine au club de
foot c'est vérifiable
venez faire des reportages sur cette
idée le club de foot années à réaliser
mais ne prenez pas le cas c'est pas un
procès contre les clubs dessus bord
d'une façon générale j'en fais pas mais
j'ai dû cesser les drisses c'est
l'exemple l'exemple qui épris de la
douche l'exemple qui est viré de chez
moi je vous parle concrètement aussi il
faut bien qu'on m'écoute aussi mais ça
fait trente ans que je veux qu'on
m'écoute
il ya un besoin il ya besoin de remettre
les cadres légaux c'est-à-dire que une
loi de 1901 pour un club de foot cette
pratique du foot
la loi de 1905 dit ce qu'elle dit c'est
dit son nom et tout le reste c'est du
domaine de la laci ce que je réponds oui
mais je m'en vais en donner
stop vous les comparez sur les plateaux
bas ont pas non mais je suis pas masquer
réponse de bagdad et avec une question
quand même est-ce que
au delà même de ses pratiques que vous
avez repéré
est-ce que parfois les clubs de sport
sont aussi d'aider des éléments de la
radicalisation des instruments en tout
cas d'arrêt des qualités très attention
avec avec cet amalgame qui est fait en
revanche ce qui ce qui est certain c'est
que les choses ne sont pas ouvertes les
choses ne sont pas dites
on va pas dire tu vas tu arrêtes ton mac
c'est tu vas venir près avec nous c'est
pas là c'est pas la question en revanche
elles sont rendues possibles à un moment
donné dans certains dans certains clubs
dans certaines associations sportives et
par ailleurs à ce que disait crise c'est
qu'elles sont vécues normalement comme
si c'était la normale si c'est la
réalité et c'est là où après on entend
son son son témoignage en disant tout
est foutu et c'est parce que c'est
normal et donc
sellal c'est la loi entre guillemets la
loi humaine la loi vécu en revanche ce
qui est important c'est c'est au
contraire de rappeler qu'elles sont
quelles sont les règles qu'elle est
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la laïcité
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
la neutralité c'est ce qui est possible
qu est ce qui n'est pas possible dans la
religion dans le sport dans l'espace
public pas que dans le sport d'ailleurs
et c'est ça qui est très important et
c'est là où le discours du président a
commencé à être clair parce qu'il a
désigné il a désigné les mots au lieu
des séparatismes c'était le séparatisme
islamiste radicale en revanche c'était
fou sur la laïcité il ya quelques
exemples sur la neutralité l'obligation
de neutralité dans le les services
publics et l'extension aux entreprises
délégataires
mais en revanche dans tous les autres
espaces publics
on en est où dans le sport cela dit
peut-être que la loi va être préparé
puisque lé pour le 9 décembre la
racaille arguent notamment une chose que
vous clarté et aussi justement pour
arrêter de considérer que certains
certaines certains épisodes certains
phénomènes sont normaux il faut il faut
dire aux enfants
ça c'est pas dans cette voie là on n'est
pas né pour ça il faut une loi il faut
une loi claire pour aider ceux qui sont
sur le terrain et
ils sont dépassés parce que c'est devenu
la tête de rémy rémy en quoi est ce que
dans les clubs du sport par exemple
chanteuse levin est ce que vous avez des
problèmes ou est ce que tout se passe
bien font alors moi je dirais que c'est
bien content du sport parce que le sport
c'est un formidable miroir pour que des
phénomènes qui traversent la société
donc là moi j'ai pas lui non plus votre
livre madame mai mais bon là on le prend
effectivement son versant noir de la
faire il se trouve que à chanteloup les
vignes pour répondre à votre question on
se sert beaucoup du sport comme outil de
prévention c'est comme l'invention des
années puisque le maire catherine arnoux
est convaincu depuis très longtemps que
le grâce au sport aussi on peut faire
revenir des jeunes qui sont en train de
s'éloigner un peu de la république on
peut les faire devenir ainsi dans les
radars et puis les remettre sur les bons
rails
alors nous on travaille au quotidien
d'ailleurs dans l'organisation du
service et c'est quelque chose qui est
très très puisque notre service de
prévention et le service sport sont la
même direction fut sous la même
direction
donc aujourd'hui on a on a une capacité
via nos coachs sportifs aussi à repérer
des choses et à agir
alors pour pourra aller plus loin depuis
depuis quelques années pour arriver
aussi avec avec l'appel ce qui est
l'agencé pour l'éducation par le sport
qui a été fondée par l'argent finit pas
senti que ce larbaoui connais bien je
crois et on développe depuis depuis un
an et demi déjà avec le département des
civils un programme qui s'appelle le
problème des coachs d'insertion par le
sport qui figuraient notamment dans le
rapport de jean louis borloo sous
programme des couches de l'insertion par
le sport ça nous permet en fait de nous
appuyer sur un réseau de coach puisque
le coach est quand même à un maillon
essentiel une arrière de cette chaîne de
création bien social
de vigilance de prévention peut
s'appuyer sur des coachs pour ensuite
repéré de bons profils afin de les
mettre en relation avec des entreprises
et donc travailler sur le volet
insertion par l'emploi
voilà un outil pour le coup une façon
géré assez innovante d'utiliser le sport
à des fins républicaine en restant du
versant est du côté positif et en même
temps on est aussi dans le faire on
n'est pas juste dans le par léon n'est
pas juste dans le commentaire
hier c'est quelque chose de concret on
met en relation des entreprises des
jeunes sportifs via des coachs sportifs
via des clubs qui feint qu'ils font aux
liens et ça c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant
donc oui pour répondre à votre question
le sport effectivement à
chanteloup-les-vignes ces textes c'est
quelque chose en tout cas qu'on regarde
regarde avec avec beaucoup d'attention
il est copieusement au quotidien c'est
dans sa que le livre de patrick arables
bingler l'a croisé passionnant parce que
c'est vrai qu'on a et heureusement ça
marche bien on a cette idée du sport qui
rassemble heures souvient de la fronde
la france black blanc beur de 98 sauviac
de cabu qui disait le peu de morale que
je sais gelé après grâce au football
mais mais il ya quand même alors et tout
ça vous le remettez d'ailleurs pas en
cause et c'est vrai que c'est un facteur
d'intégration mais il ya ces dérives
dont vous parlez je voudrais juste avant
goût de ce vol
vous savez un mot de crise quand on
entend
mustapha salma et rémy en grand moi j'ai
l'impression jeudi vous êtes mal tomber
quoi vous êtes tombés dans des quartiers
où il n'ya pas de mec qui étions un peu
les les cojones de boost à found rémy
pour pour faire les choses bien quoi
non non non pas du tout non c'est très
pauvre qui font après la moi j'ai deux
comment s'appelle fait une idée mais je
pense que vous parlez de clubs déjà par
rapport au livre qui fallait vous me
parlez de clubs de structures
d'associations qui sont affiliés et qui
ont dit des licenciés moi je pense que
le plus gros des soucis pour la france
c'est toucher club loisirs qui débarque
et qui sont affiliés nulle part et qui
n'ont aucun licencié et déjà je pense
que ce sera un premier pas de se dire
mais comment des personnes je pense
qu'il ne fut qu'un club de foot ou un
monsieur est affiliée à une fédération
qui est un sport qui est connue et
reconnue et délégataire par une
fédération donc déjà au niveau des
licenciés
tout peut se vérifier je pense avec des
subventions de tout ça là aujourd'hui on
donne la main mise à des gens qui vont
faire du foot fan loisirs qui vont aller
faire du foot a fait du foot à onze dont
les termes ont leur permis de se
rassembler lafarge se souciant que fuse
d'inscription à l'est si on veut être
gentil un petit article médical
voilà et aucune trace de ces gens là moi
c'est plus ce problème là que je vois
c'est lui il dénonce je le connais pas
il dénonce sûrement des dérives sur des
structures associatives qu'on connaît
mais là moi je parle de structures qu'on
ne connaît pas ça va alors j'ai pas lu
voix qui bien sûr mais elle me l'avait
dit et même à dire je vais le répéter
j'allais répété également autre chose il
est bien que des gens réalistes
s'intéressent aux sujets aille au fond
des choses et fassent ressortir ces
exemples encore une fois quitté par
analystes et un responsable à la route
puisque parce que ces coups reçus à
l'elysée
tellement dans toutes les exemptions
accordées par exemple j'ai dit que vous
prenez des exemples pour contextualiser
c'est en ça que c'est intéressant et je
vous félicite encore une fois mais moi
je fais appel aux journées depuis très
longtemps pour faire ce type de travail
la communauté a fait un livre par
exemple sur sur trappe où elle a repris
effectivement ce type d exemple et qui à
contextualiser également sur la ville de
trappes donc merci bravo
la sénatrice de la même façon fait des
rapports simplement qu est ce qui est
dit par par crise qu'est ce que
finalement évoque les exemples et tout
ce que vous tout ce qu'on peut dire toi
c'est 'qui on a laissé les gens
s'infiltrait il ya un espace ont le cul
aps
on va entre guillemets je peux pas si
bien sûr je leur en veut parce que c'est
pas du tout l'objet politique quand tu
étais assez pas le mien je suis pas dans
le séparatisme je leur en voudrait pour
ça on peut pas en vouloir
même à des ennemis de trouver des
solutions pour avancer même masqué donc
oui les clubs de foot ont été dévoyés
mais on les a laissés faire nos cadets
président ya des présidents qu on
lâchait voire mieux
on utilise les outils de la démocratie
les outils de ces associations pour par
exemple faire voter des présidents à la
tête de ces clubs qui eux mêmes vont
pratiquer ce qu'on dénonce mais quand le
président est réellement dans son objet
pratique du foot il fait pas de
politique mais en tous les cas dans le
club de trappes on a répété mille fois
pas de politique attrape pas de religion
un trackpad business non plus dans le
club de trappes donc tous ces gens qui
utilisent les clubs sportifs par exemple
ils en font du business ils vont du
tissu dans des tas de choses
ils font de la politique pour être élu
ils vont également de la religiosité etc
mais si on veut bien rester sur les
objets échos et que tous nos politiques
vérifie que ce qui se passe dans ces
clubs on est bien sûr l'objet ça ne
rentre pas s'il travaille sur la
situation c'est à dire qu'il faut du
contrôle est en effet crise le dis il ya
aussi beaucoup de problèmes dans les
dents les clubs qui ne sont pas affiliés
fédération et dont on a un traçage qui
est très difficile en revanche il ya
aussi des problèmes dans ces clubs qui
sont par ailleurs souvent subventionnés
par par les mairies et donc il ya quand
même un sovkhoze besoin là dessus
patrice maintenant on l'a dit il va
falloir qu'on vérifie si les objets sont
respectées si on fait bien le thème sur
lequel on travaille le foot le basket et
ses 1 2 s'il ya des dérives ont fait des
rappels à la loi des rappels ce qu'on
veut il est question de retirer les
subventions
il est question de il est question
également de dissoudre des associations
j'attends tout ça pour le par définition
je l'attend maintenant
simplement je vous le dis au bout du
bout on fera quoi après donc on voit
bien qu'on est rentré dans quelque chose
en crise dit finalement c'est foutu mais
parce qu'effectivement il ya du taf
mais faisons le mais faisons le déjà
avec des acteurs qui le font déjà depuis
des années qu'on n'a pas écouté j'aurais
pu et aujourd'hui je suis content de le
dire oui les politiques sportives sont à
partir d'un important de pour une
commune je connais peu de mères qui
viennent voir les clubs des associations
qui les réunissent en dix ans la
politique sportive de la ville c'est
celle là moi par exemple j'ai fait ma
politique sportive dans mon club et on
l'a basé sur les enfants donc oui si on
peut rentrer dans les clubs par le biais
des enfants c'est porteur dans
l'éducation nationale
c'est porteur pour ces thèmes là bas il
faut bosser il bosse à nous de bosser et
on est plus nombreux et on a plus
d'outils à nous de le faire
pardon un peu long mais à une question
magali justement votre à la parution de
votre livre et je voulais demander si
c'est pas un peu désespérant que des
gens ne prennent pas ça aux séries par
exemple la ministre des sports oksana
matinée à nouadhibou
tout ça c'est des témoignages vidéo les
cdo dis je la renvoie simplement
ça c'était la kermesse que ce qui se
passe c'est à dire cette omerta et cette
absence de volonté chez certains
responsables publics de ne pas voir la
réalité des choses
en revanche quelques jours plus tard sa
collègue au gouvernement marlène
schiappa a dit tout à fait le contraire
disons que oui il était vraiment
question de c2c phénomène là
notamment dans le sport et
bon voilà on peut lui offrir le vif et
dire que j'avais demandé un représentant
du ministère des sports s'ils voulaient
participer à cette émission et je n'ai
pas eu de réponse sur ce qui est une
véritable gêne
en effet ces fonds sont pas seulement
sur le communautarisme la radicalisation
alors justement parlons rapidement
risqué mais je voudrais qu'on apporte
vite les autres body du sport que vous
que vous dénoncez alors il y a il ya
l'homophobie notamment qui est assez
présente dans le sport on le voit il ya
le il ya le racisme et la violence
même dans le sport professionnel
visiblement comment comme on explique ça
parce que c'est très il ya pas il n'y a
pas plus mêlés dans une équipe que enfin
il ya des gens qui viennent de partout
quoi
comment expliquer donc on se dit il n'y
a pas de racisme dans le sport et
pourtant ça existe comme beaucoup vous
expliquer ça sport comme dans la société
le problème c'est que dans la société
française et je me souviens bien d'un
témoin qui nous qui nous raconter ça
dans le livre avec patrick câble c'est à
dire que c'était un faux coup un
footballeur pro d'ailleurs qui me
disaient mais en france est raciste
avancent masqués c'est comme pour la
victoire en 98 par exemple black blanc
voilà le la fraternité des héros
nationaux deuxième tour du db
résidentiel des connais parce qu'on a
gagné et donc ça aurait pas été des
héros nationaux et une
grande histoire de fraternité le seul
problème c'est ça c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où il ya ce mythe et il
y avait une volonté aussi de considérer
le sport comme comme un idéal de
partager des idées et de fraternité on
on cache la réalité de la façon dont ils
gèrent incarné dans la société est vécu
par tout le monde avec des ruptures des
démos des dérives
parce que pourquoi et c'est là où je
voudrais revenir et que ce soit pour
l'homophobie le racisme ou les violences
sexuelles ou le sexisme même il ya quand
même cette idée que l'internation du
sport doit se faire par un homme par un
homme blanc si possible jeunes un peu
musclé quand il transpire c'est
merveilleux il est adulé parce que ça
renvoie une image de puissance
d'identité et c'est donc une personne
qui est un peu gringalet qui est un peu
efféminé ne sera pas considéré comme
cette incarnation et les vivres
commencent par un témoignage comme ça
d'ailleurs
et voilà c'est ça il pareil pour les
gens issus de l'immigration qui ne
ressemble pas à cette image connue des
figures faudrait attribuer aux sports
des figures que vous qui viennent m bape
est par exemple et qui a adoré par les
jeunes ça peut pas changer quand même le
regard qu'on pourrait avoir sur le
justement le racisme chose comme ça ceci
évidemment mais ça leur faisait aussi
mais servent
ça faisait quand même aussi beaucoup de
responsabilités sur sur les épaules de
ces jeunes garçons trop d'ailleurs
trompeuses et de chose politique sur le
sport
voilà mais surtout répondre à la
question patrice convient à la limite
comment on peut faire déjà ainsi à la
tête des associations on n'a pas un
homme ou une femme qui sous présidente
qui n'est pas chevillée au corps sur ces
notions là déjà sévrier site incite à un
président qui de toute façon si un
dans son truc qui va participer à autre
au chalutage voire pire
clairement ça va ça va pas le faire
pareil pour la radicalisation pareil
pour tous
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'on revient
toujours à cette année pas de les
solutions soient tenus sur wii mais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut également et
notamment quand il vient du ministère
des biens du ministère des sports
patrick baudet préfet puisque vous
demandez à la grille l'agrément
préfectoral qui existait un moment tdc
prévu pour les clubs et ça pourrait pour
le coup patrick karam
moi je les connais il ya trois quatre
ans et je suis intervenu dans
l'hémicycle à la région parce qu'il
lançait cette idée de charte citoyenne
mais sans englober tous ces requins
moment donné c'est il faut bien rappeler
ce qui est au delà au dessus de ce
qu'est ce qui nous unit mais il ya un
vrai boulot c'est pas simplement un bout
de papier que je vais signer c'est pas
simplement des mots même si on met les
bons mots et encore j'y crois pas trop
vous avez compris
c'est vraiment un boulot de terrain et
là on en revient toutes les politiques
sociales de terrain les moyens qu'on met
les éducateurs la formation la
professionnalisation du monde amateur
cette fois c'est un truc parce que c'est
presque la fin de l'émission
je voudrais qu'on laisse la parole
peut-être à crise c'est vrai que vous
avez eu un discours parfois très
pessimiste qu'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter et qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter quelqu'un aime voudriez que
vous apporte
et est-ce qu'on peut encore nous les
apportez nous qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
souhaiter au contenu
on continue à travailler comme nous n'a
pas de problème en comme je vous ai dit
on n'a pas de problème on vit dedans on
nage de d'après ce que je dis il n'y a
pas de
nous on n'a pas de soucis dit il ya même
des subventions
tout ça c'est aujourd'hui faveur pour
faire une action ponctuelle genre va
faire une action une année puis après la
suite s'est passé quelque chose de
vraiment de 10 dans temps je pense car
notre travail à faire au niveau
l'éducation des jeunes on a perdu toute
une génération il ya plus rien à faire
j'entends enfin des bulles parler de
séparatisme zi dans deux ans nous trois
ans va on va parler de rang classisme on
sera sur un autre terrain et là on se
dira qu'on n'a pas vu venir
non le livre est très bien peut-être un
peu en retard ou peut-être il fallait le
faire mais je ne suis pas pessimiste
c'est d'accord ses limites c'est
obligatoire ce qui va se passer va créer
un indicateur par la part par la
démographie ça se verra même regarder
même les maires ça va faire y'a pas vous
dire pas des faux faux et savoir comment
voulez que la française soit mais faut
pas il faut pas nier que la france ne va
pas basculer
c'est impossible c'est à nous de choisir
comment dire que mon travail éducatif
aussi affaire avec les générations
futures
je crois que c'est le mot faire parler
tous ces gens là font les faire parler
bien sûr plus depuis l'avant dans ce
qu'il a sur mes ceintures merci je
remercie crise d'avoir le courage de de
témoigner et c'est vrai qu'ils viennent
très souvent dans cette émission et puis
il parle
puis trouve les solutions avec nos
défauts trouver les solutions à venir
rêver en grand
voilà un peu voilà tout n'est pas perdu
quoi
en un mot non tout n'est pas perdu
je pense qu'aujourd'hui énormément
forces vives qui sans accent alain sur
tous les territoires qui sont concernés
par cette problématique dont on vient de
parler séparatisme pas que ce soit dans
les banlieues d'ailleurs ou
réalité ou dans les airs et plus loin
dans les territoires d'outre-mer aussi
un qui sont aussi confirmées par tout ça
moi je pense que il ya encore beaucoup
d'espoir on recevait jeudi dernier à
chanteloup-les-vignes un homme s'appelle
jean louis borloo qui a écrit un rapport
très inspirant en 2018 ce rapport
bon on n'a pas eu d'accueil n'a pas eu
l'accueil qu'il aurait dû recevoir mais
il continue d'inspirer beaucoup de
territoires
beaucoup de collectivités la région ile
de france s'en saisit le département des
yvelines pour ce que je connais sance y
aussi les kogis d'insertion par le sport
voyages en parler ça sent du rapport
dans l'eau les sites et éducatives
aujourd'hui ça servira pour borloo la
rénovation urbaine
évidemment reste un sujet aussi pour
pouvoir traiter cette question
cette question du séparatisme de la
réussite c'est à dire on fait les
publics aussi par la réussite du point
je garde comme l'espoir chevillé au
corps parce que si on a pas d'espoir
demain on peut pas faire réussir cette
sphère publique
donc la meilleure façon aujourd'hui de
lutter contre le séparatisme de lutter
contre eux la désagrégation sociale et
tous les phénomènes de rupture et de
repli c'est finalement l'espoir la
réussite et l'action terrain vous avez
raison de dire monsieur larbaoui parce
que ce sont les politiques les
associatifs les les citoyens qui font
qu'ils font pays qu'il faut à la
réussite de ce pays et au niveau local
aussi donc un moment
moi je pense que oui l'espoir est encore
bien vivant et heureusement parce que
sinon finalement ce serait la fin
l'histoire et ce serait donner raison à
celles et ceux qui veulent
l'anéantissement de notre nation merci
infiniment régler un grand merci
infiniment crise et et à très vite merci
beaucoup mustapha la veille dans
l'émission est malheureusement terminée
magali j'ai eu mal à la cause je renvoie
à votre livre le livre noir du sport
c'est chez plon coécrit avec patrick
karam et c'est absolument passionnant
encore une fois violences sexuelles
homophobie paris truqués racisme
radicalisation vous aborder tous les
maux du sport évidemment sans remettre
en cause les bienfaits
réellement je peux l'emmener où mais
vous pouvez l'amener jeu et va vous lui
dédicacer et et nos amitiés à patrick
âme merci infiniment à tous et à très
vite pour le nouveau numéro de paf
[Musique]